- For all intents and purposes,
there are two Americas.
I think Americans
are more divided now
than they were
during the Civil War.
During the Civil War
they were divided
on the spectacularly
important issue of slavery,
but otherwise they
were not divided.
And that's a big deal,
obviously, but still right now,
the division is on every issue.
We agree, essentially,
on nothing important.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the host of the "Dennis
Prager Radio Show."
The founder of PragerU,
or I should say the
co-founder of PragerU.
And my rabbi, even though
he's not really a rabbi,
Dennis Prager, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report,"
old friend.
- There is only one slight cloud
over our being together again.
And that at is we are no
longer living in the same city,
the same time zone,
or the same coast.
I just want everybody
watching to know I miss Dave
and I miss David.
- Well, we Dave and
David, miss you and Sue,
we miss you a lot.
We're gonna see you
in a couple weeks,
but actually-
- That's right.
- Actually that is
the perfect place
to start this conversation.
Because two days before I
officially left Los Angeles,
and when I left, you know,
it was a quick thing and
I was just outta there.
I hosted a dinner at my house
with a couple of couples
just to say goodbye.
Some of the people who were the
formative people of my years
in Los Angeles.
And you and Sue were
there obviously.
And we talked about whether
it is right or just,
or worthwhile to stay and fight.
And when you should
know it's time to go.
I obviously felt
it was time to go.
You have a little, you know,
you have other
obligations and things,
but why don't we just start
the conversation there
because yeah, you're
there, I'm here.
And yet, we see the world
in such a similar way.
And we're living
in different coasts
in very different
planets right now.
- I am not staying, this
might help give your viewers
more faith in how
committed I am to honesty.
I am not staying for the
noble reason of fighting.
I fight every day. I would
fight if I were in Florida.
But I wouldn't be
fighting Florida,
I would be fighting, wokeism,
leftism, wherever it is.
I'm not staying because I think
California is salvageable.
At this time, I do not
think it is salvageable.
People who vote for
district attorneys
who will increase death
are not salvageable.
So I'm here because there
are too many people I adore.
You two were among
them, and you left,
and I totally
understand why you did.
But I founded a synagogue here,
which means a great deal to me.
Every single week,
I have this time with
people I truly love.
I speak at the synagogue.
I'm sort of, again,
the unofficial rabbi.
And, of course, other people,
I've been here for 40 years.
It's a long time. You
make a lot of friends.
But I'm not here because
of the fight issue.
If you want to fight,
you can fight anywhere
in this country
from Montana to
California to Florida.
And I wish everybody did fight.
But specifically with
regard to California,
I'm here because of people.
By the way, if a lot of the
conservatives of California move
to other states,
that's great for the
battle against the left.
Because it increases the
non-left vote in those states.
The worry is when Californians
who are on the left
flee California
or flee New York,
and then bring the
policies that they fled
to the new states.
That's sick.
- Well, I can tell you
from being here just
for a couple weeks,
I've mentioned this on
the show almost every day,
the people that I'm meeting here
who are the new refugees here,
they know what they
fled and why they fled.
So I'm very hopeful.
- That's right.
- I'm very, very
hopeful on that front.
But, all right,
what do you think?
Let's go with that
for a little bit.
What do you think really
is the future of America,
if this mass migration happens?
If basically there'll be
sort of minorities like you
in California, that that will
be fighting the good fight,
but won't have political power.
And then we'll have
places in red states
that may be more
aligned with us.
What is the united bond of
the United States of America,
if this continues
in this direction?
Which to me, it has to
actually at this point.
- For all intents and purposes,
there are two Americas.
I think Americans
are more divided now
than they were
during the Civil War.
During the Civil War,
they were divided
on the spectacularly
important issue of slavery.
But otherwise, they
were not divided.
And that's a big
deal, obviously.
But still right now, the
division is on every issue.
We agree, essentially,
on nothing important.
And look, there's a fantasy
in me that all the big cities
of the country succeed.
It's not geographically
possible,
'cause you couldn't have a
such a non-contiguous country.
But if New York and
Los Angeles and Chicago
and San Francisco and
Seattle and Philadelphia,
if they all made their own
country and left the rest of us,
even with all the finance
that they would take,
all the money, all the banks,
it would be paradisical
for the rest of us.
But it can't happen because
of the geographical issue.
So what has to happen is I
think what you just painted.
The scenario you painted
was of people coalescing
in the states they agree with.
- And then what makes us
united? I mean, does that work?
I mean, this is-
- We're not United.
- Yeah.
- We're not.
I mean, look, I hate saying
it, I love this country.
We're not united.
Tell me an issue that
left and right agree on.
I think the rest of this
podcast could be spent waiting
for you to give me an answer.
- Yeah, well there used to
have been a healthy tension,
let's say, between
liberal and conservative,
or Republican and Democrats,
something like that.
Now it just doesn't exist,
it's just basically
bow or we destroy you.
- Well, it doesn't exist
because we're not
fighting liberals,
we're fighting leftists.
If we were fighting liberals,
there would be a United
States of America.
I mean, the list-
- If you were fighting liberals,
I'd be on the other side of you.
- (laughing) Fine, I'd be
on the other side of me.
(both laughing)
You know, I grew up a liberal
Democrat because, after all,
I'm a Jew from New York
and went to Columbia, okay?
I got all the credentials of,
I voted for Jimmy Carter-
- [Dave] Yeah.
- For which I'm still atoning.
So, I just wanna, I always
ask people who knew me,
tell me one position I
have now that I didn't have
when I was a liberal Democrat.
And there's silence.
I haven't changed,
they've changed.
- Would there maybe be one like,
so when you were a
liberal Democrat,
you were still pro-life?
I mean, now we're
talking four years ago.
- Oh, that's a good point. Yeah,
I have evolved on abortion.
By the way, not for
religious reasons.
- Yeah, I know.
- But for science
reasons, solely.
You can't deny it's a human
being at a very early age.
I mean, it's just, people
who say follow the science
are generally lying.
If they followed the science,
they would know that a
human is being killed
certainly from the
heartbeat or brain waves
when they begin, okay?
We could argue about zygotes.
There's an honorable
argument on both sides.
But not in the end of
the first trimester.
- So before we go too far,
we've done the abortion debate.
We've done the death
penalty debate.
People have seen us talk
about all those things,
but I wanna back up
to where I started,
that you already mentioned.
Because you, I do sort
of consider you my rabbi,
but you are not
technically a rabbi,
but you do host these
weekly services.
And I've gone now for years
to the high holiday services
that you host.
And I think it's, for me,
really reignited something
about belief, and faith,
and tradition, that maybe
got lost a little bit
over the last decade or so.
And I found the services
to be very moving.
You go out of your way,
not to talk about politics,
even though the room of
500 people on, you know,
Yom Kipper services are
probably going, oh man, I wish,
well, I know for a
fact this past year,
because it was about five days
before the California recall,
and everybody wanted
you to say something,
but you make a point
of not doing that.
But you relate the stories
of the Bible, obviously,
to today.
Could you have been a
rabbi in another life?
Do you consider yourself?
I mean, you went to
rabbinical school, right?
- Well, I went to Yeshiva-
- Yeshiva.
- Which is the, the beginning
of training to be a rabbi.
And I continued,
even after that.
Look, I know as
much as most rabbis.
I know more than some rabbis.
My biblical Hebrew is superb
because I love grammar.
And grammar is the
most important part
of understanding these texts,
even more important
than vocabulary.
If there's a word that
comes up, you don't know,
you look it up,
it's no big deal.
But grammar is critical.
So yes, I thought
about being a rabbi
and I realized two problems.
One, I love being Mister.
I think people, in many
ways, better relate to you
as just one of them.
It's a very distinguished
title rabbi,
but I wanted to
just be a Mister.
The other is if you
are ordained a rabbi,
you are ordained by one
of the denominations,
but I'm not denominational.
So it would've
pegged me in a way
that I didn't wanna be pegged.
So I have loved being a Mister,
but I function, in some
ways, clearly as a rabbi.
And I'm honored to do that.
- So to that point,
one of the things that we've
discussed a bunch privately,
and I think, well you've
certainly discussed it
a bunch publicly.
Is sorta what's gone on with
the secular American Jews.
That's something very
strange has happened here.
You've actually written
books that, at least,
have danced with this.
That basically so many of
the purely secular Jews
traded in all of the tradition,
all of the knowledge,
et cetera,
all of the history
for pure secularism.
Or basically I eat bagels
and I watch "Seinfeld,"
something like that.
And for me to even bring this
topic up is a little bizarre
because I have a big
identification with that.
And I pretty much watch
"Seinfeld" every night.
And there are parts of
Judaism that are so connected
to sense of humor that I
think has kinda kept us around
for 5,000 years,
which "Seinfeld" did
a joke about that too.
But can you talk about
that a little bit?
'Cause I get this a lot
from Evangelicals now
because I have so many
Evangelicals that like me,
and they'll be like,
Dave, what's going
on with the Jews?
Meaning that they're
voting for the party
that pretty much hates them.
That hates Israel against
their economic interests,
et cetera.
- So this obviously is a
topic I know a lot about
and thought a lot about.
So I have to be brief, or if
you want me to expound, I will.
But obviously I can spend
the rest of the podcast
just on this subject.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Here it is in a nutshell.
I have often said Jews are
the most religious people
in the world.
The problem is
that for most Jews,
that religion is not Judaism.
The religion is sub-secular
substitutes for Judaism.
Feminism, environmentalism
are two examples.
Socialism, Marxism.
Jews trade in God-centered,
Bible-centered religion
for no God, no
Bible-centered religions.
That's why Jews are the
founders, or among the leaders
of virtually every one
of these movements.
Betty Friedan was a
Jew and a Marxist,
was a perfect example.
And ironically, you
know I debated her,
you wouldn't know this.
I actually debated
her in my 20s.
- [Dave] Wow.
- There's a video of
it, which I can't find,
but that actually exists.
At one point, she
walked off the stage
and I couldn't care less,
I just kept talking.
And then she came back.
She called me a male
chauvinist piglet.
And I didn't understand why,
I didn't reach the
category of pig.
I still, it has troubled
me all these years,
but you know, God works
in his infinite wisdom.
One of her children
is an Orthodox Jew.
- There you go.
So I just want that explained,
when Jews leave Judaism,
they don't leave religion.
They leave the Jewish religion,
or they leave
traditional Judaism.
And then they adopt or
found other movements
that are, in their
eyes, the new religion.
From Marx to Betty Friedan, to
whomever you wish to choose.
And it's a tragedy for the Jews.
It's a tragedy for the world.
- What does that tell you
about just human nature
in terms of belief?
'Cause I've definitely
come around to this.
That my atheist friends, some
of whom are your friends too,
that they end up believing in
something one way or another.
I think that's in essence
what you're saying.
You can trade all that stuff
in for another set of views-
- Right.
- But you're gonna end
up believing in that,
and usually it's kind of worse.
- The brilliant line on that
is attributed to GK Chesterton.
But I don't know if there's
proof he actually said it.
But the guy was so witty,
he might have said it.
And here it is.
"When people stop
believing in God,
they don't believe in nothing.
They believe in anything.
And here's your proof.
They believe men give birth."
Okay? That's the proof
of Chesterton's line.
They don't believe in nothing.
They believe in anything.
If you're a college
graduate today,
you not only believe
men give birth,
you believe that to deny men
give birth is to deny science.
- You, by the way
said in essence,
that on "Bill Maher,"
you know what basically about
a year ago and the media
went crazy.
- Two years ago, two
and a half years ago.
- Two years ago.
- Was it that long
already? Geez.
- Right before COVID.
- What a time warp.
So-
- You've seen it, but your
viewers can watch this,
it's somewhere on YouTube.
Dennis Prager, Bill Maher.
I'm sure it'll come-
- Yeah, we'll lay the
clip in right here,
so people get to see it.
- The left wing says,
I'll give you gigantic
lies that the United States
is a racist country.
This is a lie.
This is a gargantuan lie.
This is the least
racist, multicultural,
multiethnic country in
the history of the world.
That these people
believe it is proof to me
about how effective
lying could be.
This is an unbelievably
non-racist country.
Have you people been to Asia?
Do you people know
that the Japanese
did not allow one
Vietnamese boat person
into Japan because
they're not Japanese?
We allowed them into America.
- What is that?
- [Dennis] That's
a giant, no we're-
- We're better
than the Japanese.
- No we're better than everyone.
- What sort of a dumb
argument is that?
- We are less racist than
any country with many races.
- [Bill] Okay.
- But the President tells-
- It's a lie.
- More lies than have
ever been documented.
- But we could still
have some racism left.
- Of course, there's
racism, I'm a Jew.
- [Bill] Oh, okay.
- There are
anti-Semites in America.
It is a giant lie that
America is antisemitic.
I taught Jewish history
at Brooklyn College.
I know it. I wrote
two books on Judaism.
- [Bill] Yes.
- This is the least
antisemitic country
Jews have ever lived in.
To say America's
antisemitic is a lie.
to say it is racist is a lie.
- [Bill] Okay, well-
- These are giant
left wing lies.
- We're talking about degrees-
- To say that men can
menstruate is a lie.
And that is now,
that is what is said.
(audience laughing)
- Wait, wait, wait,
where did that come from?
I never heard of that before.
- You never heard it, well
okay, check it out, folks.
Check it out.
Anyone who says a man
can not menstruate
is considered transphobic.
- I missed this whole story.
- [Dennis] You did.
- I did.
- He said, "Oh, Trump lies,
Trump lies, Trump lies."
I said, "It doesn't
compare to left lies."
"What are you talking
about, Dennis?"
"Well, America systemically
racist is a gigantic lie.
And so is men menstruate."
And he just laughed.
And the audience was
laughing all at me.
Where the hell did I come
up with that goofy line,
men menstruate?
That was just two
and a half years ago.
- Alas.
- And now he's making fun
of the emoji from Apple
of the, what is it,
the pregnant man?
- The pregnant man, yeah.
So what-
- Yeah.
- So actually help
me as my proxy rabbi.
One of the things I've been
talking about on the show a lot
for the last two months,
maybe more than anything else,
is my last remaining
liberal friends.
So the Bill Maher types
who get it on free speech
and they get it on wokeism.
And they get it on critical
race theory and all this stuff,
but they seem unable to
get to the end of the road.
Which is that perhaps
liberalism, in its modern sense,
or the Democratic Party
in its modern sense,
or some version of those things
is what led to all of this.
And they might have to vote
for you scary
religious Republicans.
What do I do with these people?
I wanna be open,
but I also wanna get them
to the end of the road.
- Okay, you are so right.
So here is my story.
And this will answer
your question.
- Thank you.
- I think, right.
- For solving this one for me.
- Yep, yep, no, but
you're not gonna be happy.
Here it is.
So I grew up an Orthodox Jew
I'm still quite observant,
but not fully Orthodox.
And I, of course, kept
kosher for all of my youth.
Then when I was in England
for my junior year,
I figured it wouldn't
hurt my parents' feelings,
and I violated every
ritual law in Judaism
because I didn't want
to observe out of habit,
but out of conviction.
And then I came back
to many of them.
So for much of that year, I
didn't keep kosher at all.
And I remember, this is
what I wanna tell you,
what this has to do
with your question.
So I remember the
first time I ate ham
and it was a somewhat
emotionally jolting experience.
Now, fast forward.
I also remember the first
time I voted Republican.
And I want you to know that
that was tougher emotionally
than the first time I ate ham.
I thought I was
betraying everything good
that I had ever learned.
I had gone over to the dark
side by voting Republican.
That that is how deep
the belief in liberals,
forget leftists, is that
as bad as the left is,
I can't vote Republican.
The toxicity of the message
that the danger is on the right
has been so effective
that Bill Mahar
could never vote Republican.
- Look, you may be right.
And you're probably
more of a realist
and maybe I'm still a
little bit of a dreamer,
but I'm gonna work hard on
getting the guy to move.
Like these last people-
- Oh, I know we have to work.
- Yeah.
- He who saves one
life is considered
to have saved the whole world.
- By the way, my friend,
I don't know if you've ever
seen any of these videos
on PragerU, but there was
a guy, very handsome guy,
by the way, who did a video
that was all about people
leaving the political closet.
You might find that one
interesting, very handsome guy,
beard, wore his
shirt open, jacket.
- I don't remember him as that
handsome, it's interesting.
It's funny, we have some
handsome presenters.
- Anyway, we'll send you the
whole catalog. You'll dig it.
All right, I wanna talk
about COVID a little bit.
Because I went with
you in October of 2020,
a month before the election.
I said to you, "Dennis, you
gotta come with me to one
of these Trump rallies
in Beverly Hills."
I had gone the week
before, by accident.
I had driven past one after
breakfast, and I said,
I'm just gonna walk in
there and see what happens.
It was the most
joyous, spectacular
thing I had ever seen
from a political
perspective, at least.
And I called you the next day.
I said, "Dennis, you
gotta come to this thing."
We go to this thing.
This is that, you know,
still at the peak of COVID
or whatever you wanna call it.
There's thousands of people,
smiling, happy, dancing,
singing, joyous.
And as we're walking to
Santa Monica Boulevard,
we had to park a
couple blocks away.
You said to me, and neither
one of us were vaxxed.
You said to me, "You know
what, it would probably be good
if I got COVID here."
That's what you said.
You then did get COVID about
a year later and were attacked
in the most vile ways on
Twitter and everywhere else
for getting COVID
while not vaxxed.
I think you see where
I'm going with this.
Can you just lay out what
your story was on all of this?
And I also wanted to give
you credit, actually,
I'm doing too much talking
as the interviewer,
but I wanna give you
credit on something.
You said back in April of 2020,
which is now almost
two years ago,
your exact quote
related to lockdowns,
"The worldwide lockdowns
are the greatest mistake
in human history."
That's what you said
basically two years ago
about all this nonsense.
Then we walk into a rally
and you were prepared
to get COVID.
You didn't get it there.
You ended up getting
it about a year later.
Longest question I've
ever set up, take it away.
- No, don't in any
way be apologetic.
I love listening to you anyway.
But okay, there are two separate
issues, they're related.
One is what I'm very proud
of the fact 'cause it took,
I have to admit, but
you're courageous yourself
so you know this.
And that's the greatest
compliment I could offer.
You're also handsome, I was
kidding about the video.
- You're looking
pretty good too.
You lost a little
weight, didn't you?
wight, you look good.
- I look good, I don't
know if I lost weight.
Okay, thank you.
By the way, I hate
being told I look good.
'Cause I heard many years
ago this great line.
There are three ages in
life, youth, middle-aged,
and you're looking great.
So every time somebody
says I'm looking good
or looking great, I go, oh crap.
- It's better than the
alternative, my friend.
- Yes, that's right.
Well you don't look so good
there, I acknowledge that.
- Yeah.
- And anyway, so yes, so
it took some courage to say
in the second month
of the lockdown,
it was the greatest
mistake in history.
I made clear, I wasn't
saying the greatest evil.
There were so many
evils that dwarfed this.
But in terms of mistake,
there's nothing comparable.
It turned out by the way
to produce some evil,
but still, it's still
the greatest mistake.
I was right.
What has been done to
children around the world
is a form of child abuse.
The likes of which we
have not seen except
on individual levels.
We have not seen communal
child abuse like we have now,
masking five-year-olds and
two-year-olds on airplanes.
Masking the kids
outdoors at recess.
Not allowing them to go
to school in many cases
for nearly two years.
And when they go, to be masked.
This has all been a
form of child abuse.
What we have done
to small businesses
and made the wealthiest
scum unbelievably rich,
like the tech giants.
All we've done is
transferred wealth,
the lockdowns have transferred
wealth from the middle class
to the ridiculously upper class.
That's all it has
done economically.
Needless to say,
what we have done with
in terms of inflation.
Everything about the
lockdown has been disgusting
and they didn't work.
That's the irony.
They didn't work.
And any American who cares
at all about truth knows
that the states that
locked down did no better
than the states that
did not lock down.
We had a real experiment here.
Not one child, not one
child in Sweden died
and they kept their schools
open all of the pandemic.
They didn't close them for a
day. Kids didn't wear masks.
Why didn't people
use that as a lesson?
I don't know, 'cause people
don't follow science.
They follow fear.
So I was right.
And I say periodically
on my show,
I've been right on virtually
every important issue
for 40 years.
This is not a brag.
It's either true or not
true. Yes, it is true.
And why is it true?
Because I'm only
committed to what is true.
I don't have any other agenda.
What is true?
That's why I can't be a leftist
because truth is not
a left wing value.
It's a liberal value.
It's a conservative value.
It's not a left wing value.
That's why the left
suppresses dissent.
Truth is Pravda,
it is what the communist
party says is true.
Pravda means truth.
As regard with my own COVID.
Yes, I believed that
from the beginning,
or nearly the beginning,
I studied this a lot.
It is better to have natural
immunity than anything else.
And I did not believe
I would die from COVID.
I didn't believe I
would die from COVID
because I was taking
hydroxychloroquine, and zinc,
Vitamin D, and Ivermectin
for the entire year,
or year and a half.
And I believed that
it would ensure
that I would have a mild case.
And I got Delta, the tougher
one and nothing happened.
I got chills for
about three days.
I lost taste for half a day.
That was the worst part.
Cheese tasted like plastic.
And then I broadcast
three days later.
So I was right.
By the way, just one
horrible thought.
Harvey Risch of Yale
School of Public Health,
Epidemiologist, said on my
show about half a year ago
that American doctors,
American medical institutions
have probably killed hundreds
of thousands of Americans
by denying them therapeutics.
I believe that to be true.
My view of American
medical institutions
and many doctors has
gone 180 degrees.
Doctors saved my life. I will
always be thankful to them.
My surgeries were
100% successful on my
back and on my neck.
And I've been great.
So I'm very grateful to them.
But I, at the same time,
they are responsible,
I think Harvey Risch is right,
for hundreds of
thousands of deaths.
Because of their unscientific,
irrational opposition
to therapeutics such
as Ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine.
- So I don't know that
you've said this publicly,
but a few days
after you had COVID,
Sue called me and she said,
you're not gonna believe this.
Sue's your wife.
She said, "You're not
gonna believe this,
but Dennis woke up
in the midst of COVID
in the middle of the
night in the sweats.
And he turned to me in
bed and said the Davids,"
meaning me and David, "Are
moving from California."
It was before we had announced,
we were moving to California.
You had some sort of premonition
in the midst of COVID.
What do you make of that?
- Well, what do you
make of the fact
that I'd wake up in the middle
of the night with COVID-
- Thinking about me.
- And say that to my wife?
I mean, I'm blown away.
(both laughing)
- You were in COVID mania
and you had a premonition.
- Yes.
- And then three weeks
later I'm outta there.
- Well, I guess so.
It also shows you how much I
knew I would miss you guys.
I just want you to
know we're very close.
Your viewers are
free to know that.
- They can judge us
accordingly. What do we do?
This is what I went on a crazy
rant on my show this morning.
And I don't do the
rant that often, right?
I'm a pretty measured guy.
But what do we do to the
people that got us here?
And the people that
are still dragging us
into this endless pit of hell?
The Kathy Hochul in New York.
The Eric Garcetti
who holds his breath
when he takes pictures.
Gavin Newsom, you
know all the people,
the people who are
still doing it,
despite no scientific evidence.
Do we need to have some
kind of Nuremberg trials?
I mean, should they be just
banned from public office?
Like what would a
healthy society do?
And I guess, I mean this not
only at a political level,
but for you also at a
either philosophical
or a spiritual level,
it doesn't seem to me that if
we're ever gonna really heal
from this thing, we
can just move past it.
Like we're in the phase now
where we're moving past it,
'cause the Democrats
are realizing they're
gonna get crushed
in the midterms.
But we need to remember
what these people did.
What would a healthy society
do in this greatest mistake
of all time as you describe it?
- Right, by the way, you
hit the nail on the head
with your line, your
penultimate line
of we need to remember.
So I was saying on
my radio show today,
'cause there's a big
recall for George Gascon.
- Yeah.
- The evil-
- Evil.
- Moron, who is the
evil fool, not moron.
Who was the district attorney.
And the recall campaign
against him last year-
- In LA, in LA.
- Yeah, in LA, he's
the district attorney.
He's just like the one in
Philadelphia, San Francisco.
These are the George
Soros funded people.
Who's sole agenda is to
increase murder in the cities
in which they work.
That is their agenda. I truly
believe that, by the way.
Now, if you said to them, do
you want to increase murder?
They would say, no, we want
to decrease the imprisoned.
But they're the
same thing, okay?
It's like you can't
have hot snow.
You can't have less
imprisonment and less murder.
It's just, I'm sorry,
but adults actually,
you don't have to be an adult,
a five-year-old would
understand that.
Before they go to college,
they understand a
lot more about life.
So I said, it's interesting,
they probably will
recall Gascon now
'cause of the murder
rate in Los Angeles.
And this is what people do.
They elect the left.
This is the history of
Latin America, for example.
They elect the left.
The left destroys their
freedoms, their country,
and their economy.
And then they put
the right in power,
which fixes things up
to a certain degree
or more than a certain degree.
And then they think,
ah, we need more equity.
And then they reelect the
left and it's all a cycle.
People will not remember
what the left did to destroy
this country two years
after the right fixes it up.
Look at how Trump
fixed this country.
I just had Jason Riley on,
he's the brilliant black writer
for "The Wall Street Journal."
- [Dave] Yep, yep.
- And he wrote this
book, "The Black Boom."
And the guy can't stand Trump,
but he also loves truth more
than he can't stand Trump.
So he writes a book about
how good the economy was
for blacks,
unprecedentedly good.
But do people care?
No, they don't care.
The people who claim to care
about blacks voted for Biden.
Who's ruining things for
blacks, and for whites,
and Hispanics, and
everybody else.
The man is a bad
man and a disaster.
The worst human being to
ever be elected president,
in my opinion, as a human being.
I think Trump is saintly
compared to Biden.
So this is what,
there is no memory.
That's the long answer
to your short question.
There is no memory. People don't
remember what the left did.
They don't remember.
Listen, Stalin is
popular in Russia.
The man who murdered 20
to 40 million Russians
and Ukrainian Soviet citizens,
is popular in Russia.
Mao is popular in China. He
killed 60 million Chinese.
Now for every one of
those whom he killed,
think of the ripple
effect of the people
whose lives were ruined
because of that death.
And he's popular.
His picture is
ubiquitous in China.
People don't remember
left wing evil.
They only remember
right wing evil.
- So if we accept
that, and I do,
I accept that people
don't remember.
And I accept that these
things are cyclical.
And the left ruins things
and then the right fixes it.
You know, I come from New York,
they're in New York
City, David Dinkins.
- Right.
- Demolished, progressive
lefty, demolished New York City.
Who had to fix it?
Scary Rudy Giuliani, scary
in air quotes obviously.
But okay, but putting
aside that we accept that,
what could, in
your perfect world,
what would we do to
break that cycle?
I mean, what would
a healthy society,
not what we're in right now,
what would a healthy society
do so that we would not forget?
So we could break that cycle?
- There are many answers
to that question, Dave.
The first thing that
came to my mind,
it may not be the
first thing to do.
But the first thing that came
to my mind is take your kids
out of school,
homeschool your children.
That is the greatest
single good I can think of
to demolish the evil
that the left has become.
Because the roots of it
are all in education.
For all of my career I
have had this line, Dave,
I'll take a call and
somebody will say something
I consider particularly stupid.
And I will then say
in my dead pan manner,
"Sir, I'm just curious what
college did you go to?"
And you know, I've
really set him up,
'cause he'll be then say,
"What makes you say
I went to college?"
Which prepares me
for my prepared line.
And that is, "Because only
someone who went to college
would say something
that stupid."
And the only exception to
that is graduate school.
You become even more stupid.
Do you know that
"The New York Times"
even published that,
with graduate school,
then I'll come back
to what we can do.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- In graduate school, as
you get more educated,
you are more fearful of COVID.
In other words, everything-
- Yeah, what more do you need?
- About schooling-
- Yeah.
- I'm sorry.
- Yeah, how much more
info do you need?
The proof is in the pudding.
They make people
believe everything.
- The proof is in the
pudding, that's right.
Every awful thing increases
as you get more educated.
Now, not real educated.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- I'm crazy about education.
But if you love education,
you must hate most
of American schools.
So the first thing I
think about what to do,
take your kids out
of the schools.
That defunds the schools,
not defund the police,
defund the schools.
Take the money and give it to
parents to do what they want
with it to educate
their children.
So that was one.
All right, but you're really
asking, if I have it correctly,
is what do we do
about the bad guys?
- Yeah, the people who have
done this and continue to do it.
- Frankly, yes, all right.
Correct.
I am only interested
in defeating them,
not punishing them.
Not that you are wrong.
I've actually done a show 'cause
I've done an hour on every,
I did an hour on women's shoes.
I care about everything.
I mean, I really don't
care about women's shoes,
but I was curious
why women do you.
- You love those Jimmy
Choos, I know it.
- So anyway, I'm sorry?
- You love those Jimmy Choos.
That was the only women's
shoe I could think of.
Someone gimme a women's
shoes. Manolo Blahnik.
- Oh, okay, I don't
even know that one.
- I don't know.
- Okay, you're one ahead of me.
So I did an hour on
what do you emotionally
get more satisfaction from,
rewarding good people
or punishing bad people?
(laughing)
That's how my brain works.
And anyway, I'm with you.
I get more pleasure on
punishing bad people
than rewarding good people.
- Well, I'm not sure
that's my position-
- Having said that-
- I just think these
people have to be punished
to some degree.
- Oh, okay, fine.
- I like to help good people.
I know you do too, of course.
- You're right.
But that's sort of,
it's almost utopian.
All we have to do
is defeat them.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Okay, whether they lead a
miserable life afterwards or not
it is of interest to me,
but not nearly as much
as defeating them.
That's what matters
to me the most.
I mean, George Soros, I
think God will punish him.
So I actually, I get
immense, not some,
immense peace from my
belief that a good God
governs the universe.
Because there is so
much evil in this world,
and it bothers me
that there is so much.
That belief that God
ultimately makes things right
in the next world,
in the afterlife,
gives me tremendous solace.
I think Soros will be punished.
The man is diabolical.
And I mean it,
literally diabolical.
I don't even believe
in the devil,
and I think he's diabolical.
- That's what we'd
call a condemnation.
I wanna back up to something
you mentioned a few moments ago.
- Yes it is.
- You said "The New York Times."
So let's talk about
"The New York Times"
and mainstream
media for a minute.
Because I'm 45-years-old,
you've got a couple years on me.
And from where I'm sitting,
it seems that in
the last 10 years,
mainstream media,
corporate press,
whatever you wanna call it,
that it's just become nothing
other than lies, and nonsense,
and obfuscation of truth.
And almost complete
180 of reality
on almost every
important issue period.
And, you know, they
defend Democrats,
and Republicans are
always racist, okay, fine.
A lot of people say
to me, well, Dave,
it's always been like this.
Now my new conservative
audience will say,
Dave, this is what we were
screaming about in 1980.
Do you think it's
always been like this?
Is there some new version of it?
Because now we can expose it
thanks to internet video clips
and that we can see when
they chop the word not
off the beginning of a sentence
or something like that,
Or is this the same old game
that they've been playing
maybe since the fifties?
Maybe since TV news
really started, sixties?
- My belief is that
they were always biased.
But that the level of lying,
the level of editorializing
in news pieces,
the crackpots that they
published on the opinion page.
I mean, James Reston was
their sixties, seventies,
maybe eighties giant.
He was a pure liberal,
I didn't particularly
care for his columns,
but they would be
considered today centrist.
When I read Charles M Blow,
who all he does, I mean,
I wonder if he spends more
than an hour on any column.
I wonder if he spends
a half hour on many.
During the Trump era,
it was all about how
horrible Trump was.
It's fascinating,
do you know that I
made, I just cursorily,
I went through Charles
M Blow columns.
And I took out
adjectives that he used
to describe Donald Trump.
- [Dave] Uh-oh.
- And I came out with about 30.
And that was just
looking, you know,
cursorily through
a number of them.
The level of evil and moronity,
which is probably
owned by Paul Krugman.
No, he's just a vicious idiot.
He's gives a bad name to
the Nobel Prize in Economics
that he won one.
But I'm not a Nobel Prize fan,
outside of the sciences, anyway.
But anyway, long story short,
it was always like this.
The reporting from Vietnam
was biased, as an example.
Of course, they completely
downplayed the Holocaust
during the Holocaust.
That's one of they're
well-known things.
They completely, they denied,
they didn't even downplay.
They denied that there
was a famine in Ukraine
induced by Stalin to
murder, genocidally,
about 6 million Ukrainians
starved to death in a couple
of years, 1932 to 1934 or
'31 to '33, whatever it was.
And they denied it.
They literally denied, their
reporter James Duranti,
put up in a beautiful
apartment by Stalin,
and supplied with
the luxuries of life.
The guy denied it, denied
what was happening in Ukraine.
So it's not new, but
it's far, far worse.
Do you know they
fired their editor,
their longtime
opinion page editor,
'cause he invited a Republican
Senator to write a piece?
- Yes, I do know.
And here we are.
They don't have an
ombudsman anymore, right?
I mean they have
nobody regulating.
- Oh, that's interesting.
I didn't know that.
- Yeah, I don't think they do.
There's nobody regulating
the paper anymore.
- That's right.
- Yeah, so what-
- You know who's
regulating the paper?
25-year-old,
30-year-old woke women.
- So what do we do?
Do we have to, this will sort
of get us to the big tech part
that I wanna discuss
with you as well.
But do we just have to
build all new everything?
And I'm talking everything-
- Yes.
- From our janitors-
- Everything.
- To our tech solutions, to
our construction workers,
to our banks.
- Well, I don't know
about janitors and
construction workers
because I think most, certainly
the construction workers,
are probably more sophisticated
in their understanding
of life than most
Harvard professors.
And I mean that literally.
- Yeah.
- I never engage in hyperbole.
I think that Buckley's
comment about, you know,
rather be governed by
the first thousand names
in the Boston phone book
than a thousand
Harvard professors
is an entirely accurate one.
But no, we have to change.
We have to create
our own institutions.
That's what we have to exchange.
Yes, look in its way,
I say it with a
completely straight face,
I would be happy to be
put on a lie detector
to test my honesty
on this matter.
The vast majority of people,
if they don't have their
child studying STEM,
science, technology,
engineering, or math,
would do infinitely better
having their kid
watch PragerU videos
and write an essay on each one.
And read the bibliography
that accompanies the videos,
then go to Princeton.
- But Dennis, Dennis,
I've seen the critics
and they say that they put a
U at the end of his last name
and they're pretending
to be a university.
What are you doing?
- Yes, we're teaching
people facts and about life.
We're giving the most important
thing in life, wisdom.
Facts are easy to transmit.
Wisdom is a challenge.
You know, I'm having
my Passover service.
I've been working, as you
know, on the rational Bible,
the third of five volumes
is coming out for Christmas.
And it's the bestselling
Bible commentary in America,
I'm proud to say.
Costco ordered 35,000
copies of "Deuteronomy."
How's that for an achievement?
- Yeah, that's not-
- That that's a big
deal, I have to say.
I'm very proud of that.
Because I don't know who at
Costco could spell Deuteronomy.
- Yeah.
- It's not meant as an insult,
it's just meant
as a fact of life.
- The E ad the U
get confusing, yeah.
- The E and the U, the fact
that you even knew that
shows you how much
reading you've been doing.
- I'm learning, yeah.
- In the scriptures,
as they say.
Anyway, so I departed for
a year 'cause of COVID
'cause they delayed
the Bible commentary.
I did a commentary on the
oldest holiday in the world,
Passover.
It's literally the oldest
holiday and the most important.
It is the most important
holiday in the human history
for many, many reasons.
And Christians will relate
to it 'cause the Last Supper
was a Passover seder.
So I'm explaining it in the
rational Passover Haggadah.
Haggadah's the Hebrew
name for the service.
And this is my way of bringing
these ideas to more people.
So back to your institutions
about substituting
for institutions,
we need to create a brand new,
look, the religions failed.
My latest column is on the
failure of America's religions
in COVID.
How rabbis, priests, and
ministers went like sheep.
They just, yes, yes government.
Whatever you say, government.
Oh, there's no a reason
for our people to show up
for services.
It's much more important
to keep social distancing.
I mean, if you can't look to
rabbis, priests, and ministers
for courage and dissent from
irrational governmental orders,
we're in trouble.
And we are in trouble.
- I have to say, that's partly
why going to the services
that you've held, you've
been doing it for years,
but you know, I've gone for
the last five or six years
or something.
That's why it's
been so important
because even last year-
- That's right.
- Which was still in
the middle of COVID
and you guys let people-
- That's right.
- If you wanted to
wear a mask you could.
- 400 People, you wanted
to wear a mask, fine.
99% of the people didn't.
Nobody got sick and
everybody got inspired.
Which is a very good
thing for your health.
- You think?
You think a little inspiration
is good for the health?
You think that?
- Yeah, I tend to think that.
- You shouldn't just
be fearful all the time
and live in a place
where there's zero risk
or something like that?
- So, listen to this.
This is awesome.
If you don't walk around
scared you have left the left.
I mean it literally,
I mean that literally.
Look it, they believe the
world is coming to an end.
Remember, it's their word.
Existential threat of
global warming, existential.
That means of the existence.
These are scared people.
COVID will kill them, will
kill their five-year-old.
How fast can I get
my child vaccinated?
Michelle Goldberg, "New
York Times" columnist,
she was counting the days
'til that she could
inoculate her kids,
even though kids
don't die of COVID.
Only overwhelmingly old
people, overwhelmingly.
- Do you think it would've
been completely flipped?
If Trump had won,
if Trump was the president
for these last two years
and had been saying the
exact same things as Biden.
And Fauci was saying
the exact same things
and all the mandates
and all that,
do you think it would just
be completely flipped?
And all of the lefties now who
are completely for mandates,
but they'd be saying, well,
it was Hitler
pushing the mandate.
They they'd all be
anti-vaxx, right?
I mean, is it that simple
really in some instances?
- No, in that case,
we had an experiment
of that for one year.
Look, he's the one, you know,
warp speed for
getting the vaccine.
- But he didn't do mandates,
that's the difference?
He didn't do mandates.
- Oh yes, that is, oh, so you
mean, had he done mandates?
- Had he done mandates, yeah.
- Oh, that's very
interesting. I don't know.
And I'll tell you why.
The question is for a leftist,
what is a more powerful force,
hatred of Trump
or fear of COVID?
And I believe I have come,
this is perfect setup for
me to make this point.
I thought until
the last two years,
that the most powerful
drives in the human being
were love and hate.
And I now have reconsidered.
I believe it is fear.
I think fear is more
powerful than love
and more powerful than hate.
So I think fear of COVID would
have trumped hatred of Trump.
- All right, so let's talk
about fear for a second.
Because one time I asked you,
I think we discussed this
publicly once before,
but it's worth mentioning again
because you just
brought up fear.
Right when I started getting
a little more popular
or when the why I left
the left video came out
and I was suddenly getting
hate for the first time,
just endless amounts
of hate online,
from the supposedly
tolerant people.
I got a few death threats and
people were saying all sorts
of mean things to me.
And I was worried
about, you know,
when I walked outta my
house, like I just was.
And I said to you,
one day, I said,
"Dennis, what do you
do about security?"
And you, this is exactly
what you said to me.
You said, "Dave, you know,
I've done my radio show
from the same studio for the
last 25 years or something.
And I suppose one day I could
be walking out and someone
will be there with a machete.
But when it's your time to
go, it's your time to go."
And then you laughed
and I laughed, and
I know you meant it.
And I know you would prefer
not to be decapitated.
But I think that illustrates
exactly what you're saying
about fear.
You don't have fear
related to this,
but I don't think it's
because you're magical.
I think it's because
of everything else
you're laying out
here, related maybe to
belief or your feeling
about humanity, et
cetera, et cetera.
- You know, it's
really interesting
because the left
perfect president was
Franklin Roosevelt.
And it was he who
said in the 1930s,
"The only thing we have
to fear is fear itself."
It is a great line.
Note that it's never cited.
It's never, ever cited
by even liberals.
They find that to be
a Republican line.
"The only thing we have
to fear is fear itself."
So by the way, it shows you
how America has changed.
That a Democrat, the most
liberal Democrat to hold office
prior to Barack Obama,
would say that
"The only thing we have
to fear is fear itself."
And that now is regarded
as right wing propaganda,
that line.
If you went on a
college campus and said,
who said this?
- Mm-hm.
- And say, was it a
Republican or a Democrat?
Every single person would
say it was a Republican.
That gives you an idea
of the deterioration
of the moral backbone
of the American people.
Fear is now kosher.
Teachers, the most
frightened group in America,
among the very frightened.
They hold number one.
They're gonna die from a
student who was unmasked.
These people are out
of their minds in fear.
I feel for them. I don't
know if they sleep at night.
I don't walk around
with any fear.
The only thing I fear,
ironically, is the left.
That's the only thing I
fear. They will ruin my life.
They will ruin the greatest
experiment in liberty.
They are trying to do that.
And they are thus far, they
are on the road to success.
However, not enough because
there's you and there's me.
And there are plenty of
us around, thank God.
This alternate media, where
there's so much more truth
and wisdom than in mainstream
media, is their nemesis.
And they would love
to shut us down.
And that's why we have
to seek other channels
like Substack.
Not Substack, what's the name?
- Substack, Rumble, Locals.
There's plenty of them.
- Yeah, Substack, I was
right. Yeah, Rumble, exactly.
So this, and talk
radio, I mean, you know,
people always mention, and
they're right to mention,
all these other
wonderful things,
Daily Wire, PragerU, TP USA.
There are a lot of great things.
Plus, podcasts like yours and
others, and Jordan Peterson.
You know, your dear friend,
and man I deeply, deeply love.
But talk radio, that's gigantic.
You know, all of my career,
when I've had European
conservatives on my show,
I have ended the
interview by saying this,
"You know what the
big difference is
between Europe and America
and why we are have such a more
advanced conservatism here?
Talk radio, you
have no talk radio.
It's all government radio."
And every one of them
said, "That is correct."
It's all government.
Canada is all government.
Canada doesn't have talk radio,
our neighbor of the north.
And look at how
Canadians, as I said,
in one of my broadcasts,
they should remove the
maple leaf and put a sheep.
- Well, they're
fighting right now.
We'll see which way it goes.
- Some are.
And I'll tell you,
the Canadian truckers
may go down in history.
- Wouldn't that be something,
if a bunch of Canadian
truckers were the people
that ignited the fire
that saved the world?
- Unbelievable, it would
be beautiful, beautiful.
You know, you said, this
is gonna be the last thing.
And then we're gonna keep
you for one more segment.
We're gonna do a special
segment on Locals only,
because I have the real question
I've been wanting to get to.
We're gonna put on Local.
This was all the
first hour of fluff.
But you said that you
fear only the left.
I feel I can come up with one
other thing that you fear.
You fear a bad cigar.
I feel like you
actually would fear,
or a bad two things, bad
cigar and bad audio connection
as you were listening
to a symphony.
I think that would be
fear, not just anger,
but it would be actual fear
'cause you love
those things so much.
- Eh, that's more in
the realm of hate.
- (laughing)
Goodnight, everybody.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.